this episode is brought to you by
brilliant
hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
how did a 1979 panel with David
Attenborough result in this
it's a strange question but hear me out
in the late 1970s David Attenborough was
having trouble entering China to film
his documentaries he decided to join a
committee panel in China in order to
change this Attenborough just happened
to ask a Chinese hype official Deng
Xiaoping what China was going to do
about their rapidly growing population
in answering David's question it was
here on this panel that China's one
child policy would be revealed to the
world
this policy decision would Cascade into
a myriad of problems both demographic
and economic
I've covered China's broader economic
woes in the previous video so check the
link below if you haven't caught it yet
but as for our story in China there was
now too few young people the world's
most populous country has hit an
historic turning point today China
announced its first population decline
in six decades government data shows the
birth rate at a record low but the
fewest babies born last year since the
founding of communist China in 1949 but
things would only get worse in July of
2022 when a data leak showed that
Chinese authorities have over counted
the population by over 100 million young
people
China now has too many residential
buildings and not enough buyers but the
real estate market about 30 percent of
China's GDP and 70 of Chinese wealth
tied up in the sector I don't have to
tell you that this is a big deal
at the center of the crisis is evergrant
which was once one of China's largest
property developers by sales it had 1
300 real estate projects in over 280
cities in China housing 12 million
people yet the company is over 320
billion dollars in debt making it the
world's most indebted real estate
company with the company filing for
bankruptcy and some high up officials
being arrested analysts fear that this
could be China's Lehman Brothers moment
since the Chinese economy is the second
largest on the planet it's not hard to
see why a total real estate collapse
would send shockwaves throughout the
world now that we have all of this
context how bad will it get to find out
let's take a deeper look into evergrant
itself
[Music]
cool Fusion TV
today's sponsor brilliant
a lot of the topics I cover on this
channel may seem complicated to some but
now there's an easy and fun way to learn
more about them Brilliance interactive
courses on anything from computer
science to physics make learning fun and
easy
as I've mentioned before I really like
their artificial neural networks course
I think that first principles
understanding is important it was a
great way to brush up on the
fundamentals of modern AI systems if you
want to brush up on your learning either
for leisure or in your professional
career you can get started for free for
30 days and the first 200 people to sign
up get 20 off an annual plan visit the
URL brilliant.org coldfusion to get
started
okay so let's continue
evergrand was more than a property
developer
you might be surprised to know that they
dip their toes into far-reaching Fields
as far as EVs and theme parks
for example everground new energy had
ambitious goals to compete with Tesla in
China and dominate the EV industry by
2025. they were planning 14 different
car models and 5 million cars per year
ever Grand Spring produces bottled water
and claimed to be China's largest water
source evergrand also owned not one but
four soccer teams and they participated
in China's professional League evergrad
operated 15 theme parks under the name
Fairyland which aimed to be Disneyland
in both size and service
however beneath the surface these lofty
Adventures were funded by a pile of
growing debt but more on that later
ever Grant began as a small company in
Guangzhou in 1996 they grew into a giant
due to a lucky break that happened in
the 1990s economic progress in China had
lifted Millions from poverty and into
the middle class
and what do middle-class people want
houses and lots of them in 1998 China
allowed households to buy and sell
apartments with countless Millions
gaining Prosperity over the following
years there was a huge surge in housing
demand the government incentivized home
ownership their relaxed mortgage rules
gave tax benefits and allowed easy Bank
Lending meanwhile evergran's founder Hui
Kayan saw his chance
to get started he strategically acquired
land at favorable prices from local
governments often providing upfront
payment and ambitious sales targets for
his employees this approach led to the
company's successful IPO in Hong Kong in
2009 and it transformed its founder into
a billionaire
from 2010 to 2020 evergran's Revenue
increased year on year at its peak
evergrown had a market value of 47
billion dollars and assets worth 353
billion its portfolio expanded from
residential to include commercial real
estate hotels Resorts schools hospitals
sports stadiums and cultural centers
but all would not remain well for the
property giant a series of events would
threaten evergrand and the stability of
the Chinese economy as a whole
evergrant's growth strategy was
straightforward first they would borrow
money for land acquisition and then sell
these homes to buyers before the homes
were even built they would then use the
proceeds to repay lenders and fund the
next project this approach while
lucrative bore the resemblance of a
classic Ponte scheme the consequences of
which would come back to haunt evergrant
it was an aggressive unsustainable
expansion strategy in order to work it
relied heavily on Perpetual borrowing
and it worked well for two decades but
came at a steep cost and that cost was a
huge amount of debt
but everground's massive debt wasn't its
only problem
betting on property and National Pastime
in China was causing further economic
problems to brew beneath the surface
property ownership is very important in
Chinese culture some men even deem it
necessary to find a life partner
during China's one child policy parents
sadly preferred to keep only male
children as a result today men outnumber
women for those in their mid-40s and
below
and usually if a man couldn't afford his
own property their parents would help
chip in over the past few decades
property demand has been driven in a
small part due to romantic reasons
as demand for property caused the market
to overheat even more fuel was added to
the fire and this included a lack of
other stable investment options in China
investing in real estate is preferred to
stocks or bonds as if seen as safer and
more profitable
2. easy access to credit through online
platforms and relaxed Landing standards
this helped China's household debt to
GDP ratio Surge from 18 in 2009 to a
staggering 63.3 percent by March 2023 a
three-fold increase in just 15 years
number three an increasing Trend in
property speculation
many investors bore properties in
developing areas intending to sell them
later at a higher price
before long tiny apartments in Shanghai
were fetching Sydney London or New York
type prices despite the wages in Chinese
cities being much lower currently about
70 percent of household wealth is
invested in real estate
so thinking that there was more demand
than there actually was ever Grand
overbuilt in some areas but why would
they think that there was more people
left to buy houses than there actually
were it could be because of this next
point
the one child policy was enacted on
faulty data
the literal rocket scientist who
calculated the projected population of
China song forgot to factor in declining
birth rates due to women getting
educated and contraceptive proliferation
his predictions ended up being
completely wrong the consequences of
which would be very serious last year
births in China dropped sharply to 9.56
million that sounds like a lot but it's
the fewest since 1790.
and things just get worse a 2022 data
leak from the records of Shanghai police
showed the details of 1 billion Chinese
people the league is believed to be
authentic and it paints a staggering
picture the population has been over
counted by over 100 million people to
give you an idea of the scale of the
problem the Chinese government 2020
census showed that there were 18.4
million people who were born in 2017. 30
more that were born in 2002 but the 2022
leaked data says that there weren't 30
more people born on this year but 70
fewer born than in 2002.
this isn't just a miscalculation but a
complete demographic disaster in the
making soon there's just not going to be
enough young people to support the Aging
generation
demographer e Fusion has looked closely
into China for over a decade his
findings line up squarely with the data
leaks giving them more credibility
in short Chinese property developers
built for a projected population boom
which never happened
and to add to this youth unemployment
has hit 21.3 percent making buying a
property increasingly hard for the
younger generation is
um
the culmination of all of these factors
have created vivid imagery of the
problem eerily empty concrete tasks that
dot the skyline in certain regions while
sometimes these developments eventually
see habitation today more often than not
they sit empty
no sounds of cars or people just empty
concrete towers and in some cases
they're completely demolished in one of
the most spectacular examples of wasted
resources
there's both demand for housing and
China's population growth have slowed
down in recent years developers like
evergrand are facing even more pressure
to sell their properties to repay their
debts
but collecting revenue from property
sales has been proving harder than first
thought
while the housing market was red hot Xi
Jinping was watching with a Keen Eye the
property scepter was getting out of
control an action needed to be taken
fast in 2020 Xi Jinping ordered the
authorities to implement strict and
stringent regulations that would shake
evergrand and China as a whole
these would be known as the famous three
Red Lions a strict debt reduction in
financial compliance policy that had one
main goal to reduce the economy's heavy
Reliance on the property sector which
was now approaching 30 percent of GDP
ever Grant as well as many other
developers failed to meet these
requirements they continued to
accumulate debt evergrant spent huge
sums of money on costly land
Acquisitions and overbuilding during the
property Market frenzy Ventures into
unrelated sectors such as electric cars
and theme parks had little to no
profitability moreover the company
lacked transparency and engaged in
deceptive Financial practices concealing
its true debt and cash flow from
regulators and investors
all these factors created The Perfect
Storm for everground
by 2021 evergrand owed over 300 billion
dollars
and this was owed to Banks bondholders
suppliers and investors to put that into
perspective that is more money than the
GDP of Finland or Pakistan in total
Chinese developers had debts exceeding 5
trillion US dollars stop and think about
that for a second
throw in the Chinese government's zero
covered policies the strictest lockdown
in the world and there was a great level
of uncertainty and risk around the
property sector
the stage was set
evergrand announced a trading halt in
October 2021 however it didn't give
details on why
the trading suspension lasted for 17
months and during that period evergrant
was deepened
a liquidity crisis numerous defaults and
bond payments plunging share prices and
junk ratings from Credit Agencies
in 2021 alone the company lost 81
billion dollars customers were also
disgruntled with their unfinished
properties
investors demanded refunds or
compensation this series of setbacks
over the last few years have eroded
evergrant's market value by 99 percent
from a record high of 42 billion to the
company now worth 1 billion today
on August 17 2023 evergrant made a final
attempt to save itself from Collapse by
seeking chapter 15 bankruptcy protection
in a New York Court
this form of bankruptcy protects the U.S
assets of foreign companies from
creditors during debt restructuring in
their home country
in doing this evergrant hoped to avoid
potential legal actions by U.S
bondholders while it facilitated its
restructuring process in China this kind
of bankruptcy protection doesn't
guarantee a successful debt
restructuring or even default avoidance
because it still requires approval from
Chinese courts and regulators
another massive Chinese real estate
developer Country Garden would overtake
evergrand but they would also instantly
trip over Country Garden lost 7.1
billion dollars in the first six months
of 2023. investors concerned about
potential debt defaults have sent its
stock plummeting meanwhile evergrant
shares resume trading on August 27 2023
17 months after that trading hold
and it was a disaster increasingly more
information about what's happening with
these structurings of course to post
their child up to this evergrad reported
results in a weekend it's resuming trade
today
this one's going through the floor isn't
it yes it'll just like many of the other
developers that have resumed after a
year plus of activity Evergreen
investors have 17 months of news to
react to since then we've had 85 billion
dollars of losses that Evergreen has
reported over the last two and a half
years instantly there was a massive
sell-off and the stock plunged 87 in
just one day this wiped out 2.2 billion
dollars in market value
on September 18 2023 some arrests were
made at Evergreen Financial wealth
management it's not clear what the
arrests were for but police have only
stated that they were quote suspected
criminals the stock fell another 25 on
the news
and with that Swift decline it's looking
like the once powerful giant Has Fallen
evergrant's collapse is unprecedented in
Chinese history it's affected various
sectors and people from Iron Ore miners
to steal and cement producers home
retail businesses construction workers
and more as the net worth of Chinese
citizens reduces with property prices
spending in local and international
markets will decrease
as mentioned in the previous video if
the Australian government doesn't
diversify its trading exports there
could be a ripple effect here the US
Hong Kong Japan South Korea many Western
nations in Europe and the global economy
will be affected if current trajectory
continues
and remember the middle class investors
that we spoke about earlier in the video
many of these home buyers now have paid
deposits on unfinished properties it's
another issue in This calamity evergrand
has pre-sold more than 1.4 million homes
that have not yet been delivered
many buyers are families who invested
their life savings and now they risk
losing their money on these homes
we may talk a lot about numbers and
policy decisions but this is the true
human cost
overall new construction is down at 24.5
percent just this year alone prices in
some areas have fallen by as much as 25
from their October 2021 Peaks the banks
and other financial institutions that
lent money to evergrant could face
problems of Their Own
forever Grant there's about 20 billion
dollars owed to foreign investors this
isn't to mention the belt and Road
initiative by China carried out in over
149 different countries evergrant was
one of the biggest buyers of
construction materials so it's clear to
see that with everground's bankruptcy
spilling into Global markets the
knock-on effects could change the
livelihood and well-being of millions of
people not just in China but overseas
as quoted by 14 Magazine on August 17
2023 Chinese real estate may be the
world economies most important single
sector
[Music]
so is this is the China's Lehman
Brothers moment
well the answer is not so simple yes
both cases involved a highly leveraged
and opaque sector sectors that were
critical to the economy and financial
system and both had an element of global
risk however it's important to note the
distinctions China has an advantage in a
state-controlled banking system though
whether you call that an advantage or
not depends on your view regardless the
Chinese government has already supported
the banking sector with liquidity and
relaxed some regulations to ease the
pressure on the property Market
but there's no indication that they're
going to bail out evergrant or any of
the other developers that are in trouble
authorities might even use accounting
methods to avoid major bank failures
this opinion was shared by George Mangus
a research associate at Oxford
University's China Center he States
quote
in a state banking system the
authorities can move liabilities around
the financial system and use extended
pretend accounting to ensure that major
Banks don't fail and that smaller ones
can be made good or managed as necessary
China also has a huge Foreign Exchange
Reserve and tight Capital flow control
unlike the United States which is the
world's biggest detonation China is
actually the world's biggest creditor
Nation but all of this doesn't mean that
there's going to be no damage there are
legitimate concerns about the global
impacts given the size and influence of
China's real estate economy right now
it's about damage control but it's going
to take time maybe even years to revive
the industry once consumer sentiment
changes so drastically in a housing
market that's hard to bring back
so in conclusion evergrant's collapse
marks a significant challenge for China
as we look ahead the stakes are
exceptionally high for major industry
players in the country at the same time
it's a tense moment for those whose
Financial Futures are in jeopardy at
this stage the only things that would
stop this from getting worse is
government intervention or a
stabilization of house prices on a final
note China does have many state-owned
property entities so it's very possible
that they could just take over and stem
the bleeding it's a totally different
kind of economy and with murky data it's
difficult for anyone to provide a
concrete analysis but in saying all of
this as is always the case this
unfolding financial disaster comes down
to Reckless financial decisions damaging
lives but this time there's some dodgy
government population estimates to go
along with it so what are your thoughts
on this matter let me know in the
comment section below I'm sure it's
going to be a very interesting
discussion
anyway that's about it from me my name
is Togo and you've been watching cold
fusion if you want to see anything else
on science technology or business feel
free to subscribe it's free
all right cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
thank you
cold fusion it's new thinking